hello everybody welcome it is Friday
night it is almost eleven o'clock I'm
here in believe nation Studios
headquarters just wanted to make a quick
announcement one sha sha gingersnaps are
amazing no but seriously i'm coming to
chicago this week i'm coming in on
monday a fly out on thursday i'm doing
two sessions at sage summit talking
about raising capital as well as how to
market your business one of the things I
love doing when I travel is meeting with
you guys meeting with the fans living
about your business it's one thing to
see you in the comments and meet you and
you know talk back and forth and I
really enjoy that but there's something
about meeting face-to-face understanding
your business trying to give you some
advice some motivation some inspiration
that I really really really love and so
this will be 2 opportunity from Chicago
or going to be shipped in Chicago on
this week probably tuesday night i don't
know what my schedule is exactly yet but
I'm hoping that tuesday night i can keep
free for you guys to be able to have a
meet up and i'm sorry for everybody is
not Chicago there's no way on YouTube to
just like send it to people from Chicago
so one if you're going to be a sage
summit I'm going to link up the
description below I'm going to be there
speaking Richard Branson's going to be
there Ashton Kutcher's going to be there
when it pops was going to be there bunch
of other famous people if you're coming
let me know I want to meet up I want to
take some pictures I want to chat about
your business too though if you're not
going to make it to say summit again
Tuesday night I want to get together
probably around my hotel which I don't
know where my hotel is exactly I'll find
out for like drinks kind of after-dinner
things and snag something like that and
talk about your business so the way to
find out about that is get on my news
that i'm going to send out and i was
about to send tonight i was going to
send email out to my newsletter people
who are from the Illinois the state of
Illinois but I wanted to give a quick
cheddar on youtube first for those of
you guys who may not be on my newsletter
if you're from Illinois want to get the
update sign up for the newsletter I will
be sending something this weekend to you
and hopefully we can meet up on Tuesday
and I can learn about your business and
help you out that's it i think it was in
the description save someone's in the
description the miners are description
Nina's having a shower so I got a chance
to be able to have a quick chat with you
guys we appreciate the levels of poor
thank you for letting me make this quick
little bit if you guys continue to
believe have an amazing weekend and I'll
see you soon